Oh
I don't want to see you out here again
what gives you the right what's the
difference between you and me I'm not
directed by Joel Schumacher if you're
not familiar with me I promise no
spoilers
I never spoiled my reviews you are safe
with me ever since that last shot in the
dark night where the Batpod just
disappears into the city lights I have
been waiting for this movie I've had
problems sleeping I've been having cold
sweats I'm pinned shaking this is my
most anticipated film of the year call
me a Nolan fanboy whatever yes yes I'm a
Nolan fanboy I'm sorry I'm a fan of
quality entertainment shoot me The Dark
Knight Rises picks up eight years after
the Dark Knight ended and here we have
Bruce Wayne you know he's kind of an
exile he's a broken character physically
and mentally obviously after he took the
fall in the Dark Knight things didn't go
so well for him Batman is not around
anymore people are wondering where he is
kids are you know writing chalk against
walls like bat symbols the way they
introduce Wayne's character in this
movie you really care for this guy I
mean you cared for him already for the
previous two films but he's so sad you
can just see this aura of sadness
because everything he tried to do is
Batman he just sacrifices everything for
these people of Gotham and you can just
tell this guy is broken and he needs
something he needs to come back he needs
to rise again the film opens very
quietly you know very slowly get kind of
a bleak feel of what Gotham's like now
this strange underground thing is
brewing with this Bane character played
by Tom Hardy you meet Catwoman or Selina
Kyle's character and you see where she's
going Joseph gordon-levitt plays a
detective in this movie who's
investigating everything he's trying to
figure out what's going on with a lot of
these underground things he's heard
about this this army that's brewing
everyone wants to know where Batman is
there are people on both sides who think
he was good and bad but the majority of
people aren't too sad about the fact
that he's gone now Commissioner Gordon
is one of my favorite parts of these
movies and you see his character and you
can feel that this guy is feeling
immense pressure from living under that
lie that Batman had something to do with
Harvey Dent's death or that he actually
did kill Harvey Dent and you can really
feel that eating away at his character
pretty soon certain things happen with
the Bane he affects the city of Gotham
in a certain way
affects everyone there in a certain way
and Batman has to come back and this is
where all hell breaks loose and
basically all-out war happens in the
city of Gotham between Batman and Bane
between the cops and the criminals but
Gotham is basically turned into a war
zone
and Bruce Wayne has to learn how to be
Batman again he has to rise up as the
movie's tagline States and figure out a
way to overcome this immense problem now
the Dark Knight is on my favorite movies
of all time Batman Begins is all my
favorite movies of all time Christopher
Nolan's one of my favorite directors of
all time this movie comes with so much
anticipation especially from someone who
loves Batman as much as I do and I'm
going to be honest with you if you don't
at least like this movie why do you even
go to see movies honestly why do you see
movies if you don't at least like this
movie this is one of the best comic book
films I have ever seen one of the most
emotionally resonant films I've seen in
years and it's also the best film I've
seen all year The Dark Knight Rises is
absolutely fantastic in every way that
you possibly need a movie the acting the
writing the directing the score the
visuals every technical aspect of this
film is mind-blowing it's just it's shot
brilliantly wally pfister just out does
himself in every way if you watch this
movie and you're thinking how does one
person approach this character this
comic-book character and all of these
larger-than-life people so realistically
so convincingly to set you up for this
world to get so much emotion out of the
viewer and just make you honestly like
shake with like fear of what's going to
happen in this movie because the last
like hour of this film I kept her the
last time I was that on the edge of my
seat like my knees were actually shaking
now one of the things I really liked
about this movie is that when you see
Batman Begins it's great you know you're
so surprised by that and then the Dark
Knight is a completely different tone
it's a razor-edge the tone of the Dark
Knight when you go into the Dark Knight
Rises all these films fit into place but
at the same time they're all so
different in the way they feel this film
is bleak it's sad enthralling it's
extremely exciting and suspenseful it's
scary it's funny I've never seen a
superhero film with such raw emotion at
its core and such heart for these
characters and you just so you feel so
much for the people in this movie it's
so realistic the point where you forget
sent about the fact that Batman is
fighting some guy you know with like a
thing on his face what's this cat woman
thing why is he wearing about you all of
that just fades away and you see people
you don't see Batman you see the
character of Bruce Wayne Eve you really
feel that there's a man behind there you
understand why he's doing the things
he's doing and all of these characters
fit exactly where they need to be for
one of the most emotionally pleasing
experiences I've had the theaters in
quite a long time let's talk a little
bit about Bane okay such a good villain
because let me tell you something this
is the first time as I'm sure you
realize that Batman has ever really been
challenged physically because in Batman
Begins it was very emotional was about
overcoming his own problems really and
the Dark Knight the Joker challenge
Batman's morals and the way he felt
about rules and things like that was
much more of a psychological challenge
and this film Batman is completely
outclassed he just he gets pummeled in
this movie this is the first time
Batman's ever actually felt fear for one
of his opponents so that adds this whole
extra feeling of hopelessness in this
movie you really want Batman to succeed
but you have no idea how in the world
you could ever pull it off because there
is honestly like all hope is lost in
this movie it's so well told in the
trailers you get these little hints that
Wayne is in some type of prison or
behind bars in some way that whole
sequence of the film it honestly felt
like in a way kind of like Batman Begins
like in this film it was like almost
like he had to learn how to be Batman
again go through a lot of the same
issues and and figure out like how to be
Batman at his very core and what he can
do to save the city of Gotham when he's
in such a hopeless position and the way
this film ties that together through
script and storytelling it's
mind-blowing
it I have no idea how anyone would begin
to approach a story with this much stuff
happening in it I want to talk a little
bit about the performances in this movie
this is the best performance by
Christian Bale of this trilogy is so
just deep and and sad and you really
feel for him you feel the hopelessness
of this character you just feel it so
much in this movie that he just has no
idea what he's going to do and he's just
fighting to figure out a way to do it
and he's just it's so great he is
good in this movie Tom Hardy s Bane was
great he was so entertaining like I like
the one of the ways he talked it was
like almost every statement he made was
a question like the way he would kind of
end a sentence even if it wasn't a
question that he was asking it was just
a flat-out statement he had this way of
curling his voice at the end of his
sentence as I loved and it was also easy
to understand there's only a couple
sentences in the movie I was like what's
that he was so physically imposing - you
really bought Tom Hardy as this bill and
you just you bought the fact that this
guy can beat up Batman
they really sold that in the movie this
film has one of the best fight scenes
I've seen in years that's all say Joseph
gordon-levitt plays a police officer in
the city and he is excellent in this
movie you really feel that he's one of
the last good cops that really just
wants to help he's not on the take he's
not selling drugs like the cops in
Batman Begins he's not involved with
that he's one of the last few remaining
good cops and you see him in Gordon his
character added so much of this movie
everyone in this movie is great of
course Morgan Freeman Michael Caine I
don't even have to tell you they're good
that if Michael can't ever give a bad
performance the world would explode
there's nothing in this movie that is
like another comic book movie it's the
most emotionally resonant comic book
film I've ever seen I've never seen a
comic book movie that has made me feel
this way inside so invested in what's
going to happen so on the edge of my
seat and without spoiling anything the
way the film concludes was perfect it
was so satisfying I loved it it was an
excellent way to conclude this trilogy
and it's one of the best trilogies we
have now of course the Dark Knight Rises
gets an A+ so I know you guys want to
hear me say you want to curse is it
better than the Avengers hey Chris is it
better than Dark Knight Siddartha Batman
Begins you know what I don't like to do
that kind of comparison but my buddy and
I John are going to be doing a spoiler
filled discussion
pretty soon I'm here with my buddy John
from the flick Peck Channel show you
sure you guys remember him we did a
spoiler filled discussion of the
Avengers when that came out we're going
to do that again for The Dark Knight
Rises it's going to be on his channel
it's gonna be on my channel after
opening weekend we're gonna talk in
depth about how we feel about the film
how it compares to the other films and
we're going to do a whole spoiler field
thing so look forward to that
my buddy John Batman
oh yeah that's all I can think about
honestly it's all I can think about -
buddy so that'll be soon and look
forward to that so have you guys seen
the Dark Knight Rises are you looking
forward to it what do you want to see in
the film and if you have seen it try to
avoid spoiling it in the comments for
those who haven't seen it as always guys
if you like this review you can
subscribe to my channel and get stuck
mine eyes